ce projet de loi il vient après d'autres
il vient après d'autres après d'autres
rappelons-nous la loi via qui était
destiné soit disant à lutter contre la
haine qui a été ensuite retoquée par le
conseil constitutionnel
c'était une première tentative là on
voit bien qu'il ya un problème la loi de
1881 n'est pas une loi destinée à
protéger les journalistes c'est une loi
de limitation à partir d'un impératif
d'intérêt public
une loi de limitation de la liberté
d'expression qui doit être absolue ainsi
on lit la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et notamment dans son article 11
1 elle doit être absolue elle peut être
limitée dès lors qu'il ya des intérêts
supérieurs la loi de 1881 quand je dis
qu'elle protège la liberté d'expression
pourquoi parce que comme il s'agit de
quelque chose d'essentiel
article 10 de la déclaration des droits
de l'homme qui fait partie de notre
constitution quand même article 10 c
liberté absolue d'opinion et de
conscience
article 11 liberté absolue d'expression
sauf sauf si donc effectivement il ya
des intérêts supérieurs